j'accueille ce jean roucas
voici le méchant dans les mairies les
sociologues de la terre
ils sont tous dans le vert
écoutez je vais les tongs et tu sais qu
antoine pinay a dit qu'à ton âge tu
devrait entrer au panthéon
et bien justement j'ai calculé encore 3
septennat et j'aurai l'âge d'antoine
pinay mais tu n'as pas le téléphone de
christine qu'est-ce que tu ferais si tu
est battu écoutez je continuerai à faire
de la politique que je ne sais faire que
ça
je me barry cadre est à l'hôtel de ville
et je n'en sortirait que la nuit pour
aller faire pipi sur les murs de
l'elysée
venez tous dimanche à tacen deuil
les magazines meilleurs lecteurs
bienvenue à la maison après tout le
monde en a parlé à retrouver jean roucas
dans le nord-est de paris
l'imitateur nous accueille dans son
appartement où il vit avec sa femme et
son chien monsieur figaro qu on a
dérangé pendant sa sieste avant ça
c'était un crime de chats majesté ça
voilà ma femme parce que le chat ne sont
pas d'habitude
aurais tu es tu me fasses couple comme
tout le monde comme des milliards de
gens se promènent on fait nos courses en
chine ont un vieux chat qu'on adore qu'à
14 ans ont fait on fait tout comme tout
il est moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que florence est totalement fan de son
mari c'est un excellent imitateur et mon
âge et même sur la souvenir des voix 2
de cowes theron de tout ça c'est très
bien mais très franchement comme
imitateur pour moi c'est le meilleur
alors quoi ma gueule qu'est ce qu'un
de montrer ce qu'est la bête comme chou
avec laurence gens partagent une passion
la brocante l'appartement du couple est
d'ailleurs envahi de meubles chinés et
d'objets insolites voire ultime dont de
florence d'acheter une d'acheter des
trucs qui sont inconfortables et voire
inutilisable le bureau on fait bien mais
voilà décompose un truc dessus vous
constaterez que ça tient pas jean vous
cassez florence aime se promener le long
du canal saint martin ça c'est notre
balade quotidienne c'est formidable
parce qu'on trouve ce qui est rare à
paris de la nature de l'espace de l'eau
des bateaux puis c'est un quartier
intéressant parce qu'il a tous le couple
nous emmène chez son brocanteurs préféré
installer à quelques rues seulement des
nouveautés à la recherche des causes
plus de fautes aujourd'hui ils sont en
quête d'un nouveau fauteuil
mais comme d'habitude leur attention se
portera finalement sur d'autres objets
[Musique]
tu peux le mettre dans le balcon à côté
du cendrier souvent ils chamaille on
prend ça dangereux pas là où l'autre
quoi ça dépend après bon c'est souvent
madame qui l'emportent mais pas tout
continue à monter en matière
vestimentaire également jean roch inseme
fouiner trouver des bons plans et faire
quelques économies
moi j'achète souvent mes cheveux musici
parce que
c'est de la marque et c'est la très très
bonne qualité pour le short c'est comme
pour le bureau
les avis sont partagés je laissais rang
mais oui mon pc rebond déjà là on n'a
pas eu les mêmes
allais-je pour jean c'est l'heure de se
rendre au théâtre et les spectateurs de
liberté égalité hilarité ont toujours en
mémoire les belles heures cathodique du
comique c'est le souvenir du bébête show
c'est sa tête avec la casquette
l'olympie lhotelain et tous à cette fête
light ou la grenouille qui arrive
l'aigle toutes ces choses là où tout
explose c'est surtout ça j'en conviens
se faisait beaucoup rire et c'est pour
ça que je vais le voir ce soir au
théâtre des deux ânes il est rejoint
dans sa loge par ses deux complices avec
qui il partage la fiche tout d'abord
jacques mailhot qui sait qu'elle joue
ici rapidement j'ai parlé de beauvue
mais les jean poiret il ya eu pauline
carton la simca jouer une revue et un
petit dernier avait déjà grandissantes
et laurent gerra oui laurent gerra cissé
et ses débuts et puis pierre douglas
dans les compléments complémentaires et
on parle finalement des mêmes choses
avec un style complètement différent
c'est un peu comme quand vous lisez le
compte rendu d'un événement dans trois
journaux différents
quelques secondes avant d'entrer en
scène l'humoriste et chauffe encore
saisie automatique non raccordés quand
même là pour se détendre je vous fais
une promesse mesdames messieurs à partir
de maintenant je ne vais vous parler que
des domaines où tout va bien en france
sa patrie
je rêvais que les élections
présidentielles se dérouler en plein
moyen-âge ans
dame ségolène fille de filles de ta que
nous
lors du maladroit une rime alors chirac
partant pour la croisade
[Musique]
crandall
m
il aurait mis la ceinture de chasteté à
bernadette
et en revenant ils auraient des gpo mais
la clé loin de la télé mais toujours sur
les planches
jean roucas continue de s'adonner à son
plaisir préféré bercy fait et maintenant
la lumière sera lui sur jean roucas
bienvenue ce plateau tournant à part
merci thierry bonjour alors j'en faisais
tu né le 1er février 1952 à marseille
votre père gilbert avril c'est votre
vrai nom experts en immobilier d'origine
marseillaise et votre mère kaki
d'origine corse et vous dites
marseillais corse
et pourtant je suis travailleur et ouais
c'est curieux je fais une erreur
génétique alors vous grandissez le
quartier du roucas blanc est là à l'âge
de 9 ans vous êtes déjà star puisque un
jour fait la une des journaux vous fait
renverser par une voiture sur le chemin
de l'école saint victor la voiture vous
traîne sur 300 m vous n'avez rien et
tout le quartier vous appelle le
miraculé
absolument alors j'ai aucun souvenir de
ça je les lui après dans le temps le
provençal c'était très mal de l'époque
ça que j'ai eu de la chance je suis
passé sous la voiture j'étais accroché à
un bout de ferraille par le par mon
capuchon et j'étais très déçu je suis
tombé dans les pommes très vite je m'en
souviens absolument pas jane star très
jeune alors très jeune aussi le goût du
spectacle c'est peut-être dû à votre
arrière grand père pied montée
baptistine haut qui poussait la
chansonnette dans les noces et les
kermesses
vous connaissez les chansons qui chante
hé oui il va tous nous a sauvés nt sous
la monte anna bella et l'oscal piguet
absolument vous connaissez quoi je
connais les trois tournois sereine c'est
évidemment la pointe et bella ciao
ok moi et me fasse ou non depuis que
c'était ça veut dire les les chaussures
de mauvaise qualité des strippings des
godasses ouais et comme tous les
immigrants piémontais arriver avec des
avec des pompons piteuse état on les
appelait comme ça à marseille on les
appelait les godasses et sézanne et quoi
s'adonner va conduire qu'alpiq oaxaca
mine face qui a fait ce qu il a des
vieilles godasses quand il marche ca
fait place place voilà alors en tout cas
où fait du piano et à 9 ans vous entré
au conservatoire alors à donner sens
assez sympa vous allez en solex à la
plage entre les cours et années 68 cas
un bon moment formidable
j'ai souvenir formidable parce que je
suis arrivé un jour au lycée je suis
tombé sur deux types avec des brassards
rouges qui m'ont dit toi on interdit
d'aller en cours fallait pas me le dire
deux choses je suis plus jamais aller
alors l'abattage prenais mon solex et
j'allais l'appeler alors au départ
voulais être prof d'allemand mais malgré
la fac et 12 mois à francfort vous y
arrivez pas
ben c sipa ça c'est que à l'époque mon
père mais je me disais bon tes études tu
vas te les payer il avait des idées un
peu 6e peut avancer comme ça tu vas tu
es payé alors bon qu'est ce que je
faisais pour payer mes études je faisais
de la musique et un moment donné je
faisais les balles quoi je chantais dans
les bals je me suis aperçu que je
m'éclatais beaucoup plus ce train en
faisant de la musique en faisant le coup
en sur scène que en donnant des cours
d'allemand appareils pour le service
militaire vous ne faites pas non plus je
dirais formé au bout de trois heures
on était à peu près 200 bonhomme en
était à poil dans un couloir moi j'avais
gardé mes lunettes et la porte s'est
ouverte le médecin chef est sorti il a
fait comme ça vous avez vu tout de suite
je pas pourquoi peut-être les lunettes
venez ici il ya du bon lisez moi ça ils
attirent un tableau à la deuxième lettre
j'ai foiré
elle est sortie là vous décidez de
changer de voie vous animez des balles
avec votre petit orchestre est votre
premier employeur si charles pasqua qui
à l'époque était aux relations
extérieures de ricard et vous avez fait
quoi pour charles pasqua alors avec
charles pasqua s'occuper d'une grande
manifestation c'était le podium paul
ricard qui faisaient toutes les villes
du midi toutes les plages et donc il
fallait un orchestre pour jouer 2 à
l'apéro qui ont joué à la pinède et donc
ont joué ont joué tout l'été comme ça il
était déjà le charles pasqua qu'on le
vrai qu'on a connu
alors quand vos parents ouvrent un
hôtel-restaurant il vous colle derrière
les fourneaux et lavera là vous dites
lance pas possible quoi annonce j'ai un
respect moi quand je vais dans un
restaurant vous dans un hôtel pour le
travail qui fait je vais jamais râlé
même si c'est pas un jeu c'est la somme
de travail que ça représente
là vous partez à paris sur un coup de
tête avec 50 balles en poche quoi al
aventure ah oui sans aucune adresse
ainsi gare de lyon voilà seul à brest
alors vous atterrissez chez félix à la
contrescarpe est là tous les soirs de 9h
jusqu'à l'aube
vous chantez vovo couillonnades en vous
accompagnant au plus au piano a vraiment
mais vraiment des couillonnades c'est à
dire là il fallait tenir toute la nuit
donc c'est pas évident une bourre au
bout de trois heures j'étais à sec donc
je faisait chanter les gens je serai je
sentais ce qui me passait par la tête
mais c'est bien celle-là c'est là que
j'ai appris c'est une école un oui oui
parce qu'il y avait les ivrognes les
clochards les descentes de police et des
truands des coups de feu un et aux coups
de feu moi j'ai une fois il ya eu un
échange de coups de feu au fusil de
chasse
j'ai un tronçon de plafond qui m'est
tombé sur la ville
c'est par eux mêmes peu tordu pour faire
du vin dans ces conditions alors c'est
félix qui trouve votre nom jean roucas
du nom du quartier où vous aviez été
élevé oui parce qu'il se rappelait
jamais de mots de mon nom avril s'était
rappelée et puis je lui avais dit
marseille j'habitais l'unccas alors ça
le faisait rigoler voilà et il me disait
verrou vient toile à le leur ou casse
alors bientôt ça marche un peu mieux et
c'est l'époque où où les gens comme vous
faisait 5 6 cabaret dans la nuit arrivée
le caveau de la république le don
camillo l'orée du bois enfin on vous
passez d'un cabaret à l'autre quoi ah
ouais y avait un cabaret c'est
épouvantable ça s'appelait le
pénitencier parce qu'ils avaient trois
salles avec trois spectacles différents
séparés par un petit rideau arrêts c'est
à dire qu'on sent on entendait ce que
vous aidez moi j'avais un type qui
faisait numéro comique en jouant de la
trompette
ouais mais moi j'étais au piano c'est à
côté évidemment je voulais pas le même
truc c'était horrible le monde comment
les gens pouvaient venir
c'est une école incroyable et puis voilà
c'est sur la scène d'un cabaret niçois
que vous attirez l'attention de celui
qui va faire basculer votre destin
stéphane collaro à la piñata sur les
hauteurs de nice samedi dans le quartier
qu'on appelle fabron way est donc là
c'était quand même c'est un music hall
ont travaillé sérieusement il y avait
une scène y avait c'était l'encadrement
était assez professionnel et ce soir là
il y avait stéphane collaro
eddie barclay et toute une demande qui
fêtaient un anniversaire et avec carlos
etc
alors c'était très étonné que colarôme
aux marques parce qu'ils n'ont rien
écouté du tout la soirée il était bourré
comme des cantines et je me suis dit
mais comment il a pu me trouver bon et
il a même pas écouter ce que je suis
devenu mort à la fin il m'a dit il faut
qu'on se revoie et voilà alors collaro
vous propose de participer à une
aventure télévisuelle dont on n'est pas
sûr qu'elle durera bien longtemps et lui
non plus elle a duré 13 ans ouais aller
le collaro show coco boys cocorico chaud
et surtout le bébête show des médecins
offices du muppets show et père des
guignols quoi ben oui ça il aime pas du
tout qu'on dit ça mais en france c'est
quand même
ah oui c'est un peu vrai quand même là
mais il faut reconnaître que là les
élèves ont dépassé les maîtres sûrement
bah oui alors là tous les soirs à 19
heures 55 la france entière attend
mitterrand grenouille giscard en vo tour
chirac encore beau sarkozy en caniche
balladur en pélican marché aux cochons
langue en chèvre le pen en bécassine
enfin c'est un succès extraordinaire
c'est vrai que ça a été ça a été quelque
chose d'extraordinaire et ce qui était
formidable c'est que les enfants
voyaient pas du tout le côté politique
de la chose lui voyait que des
marionnettes marrante
ça fait que ça plaisait aux enfants pour
le côté nounours en peluche qui
s'appelait aux adultes pour le côté
politique
donc ça a touché un public assez large
si tout le monde
fort de ce succès avec l'appui de
coluche que vous aviez connu chez félix
la contrescarpe là où fait les roues
kasri sur europe 1 font très très bien
marché aussi
oui ça a bien marché aussi c'est vrai
que c'est grâce à lui et je n'ai jamais
su parce que coluche c'était ça c'est
vrai que c'était quelqu'un de discret il
avait la générosité discrète un jour
hors pas m'appeler pour faire une
émission quotidienne
je me disais mais c'est quand même c'est
enfin c'est trop beau que j'ai su dès
années après c'était coluche était déjà
mort que ça c'était lui qui avait fait
des pieds et des mains pour que je
rentre europe vous voilà devenu star
voulait vécu comment ces deux célébrités
j'ai vécu mal par certains côtés quoi le
fait de ne pas pouvoir aller manger à
découvert au restaurant de ça c'est un
côté de la célébrité
très franchement que je vais donc je me
passe très bien passe très bien
aujourd'hui donc encore que encore
qu'aujourd'hui les gens montpezat et
vous connaissez c'est moi la vraie la
folie qui à l'époque
quelles ont été les réactions de trente
ouvrages c'est à dire votre votre père
il a réagi commet toujours été très
critique à mon égard mais c'était de la
critique constructive
moi moi j'aime bien la critique
constructive les miens j'aime bien qu'on
vient de me voir au spectacle et qu'on
me dise après j'ai pas aimé parce que ce
que je ne supporte pas c'est des gens
qui vous tartine wii qui disent que vous
êtes un con un ringard je peux dire des
nombres
qui carlier qui a tartiné sur moi 21
nuls un regard un has been et qui jamais
ne venu voir un spectacle et qui ne me
connaît absolument pas alors qu comment
on peut on peut porter des jugements
quand on ne connaît pas la personne et
ce qu'il fait et votre mère elle a réagi
comment on va comme une meilleure était
ravi ouais
son fils est une star vos rapports avec
les médias ça a été qu agent j'essayais
d'être sympa et tout le monde bon c'est
vrai que j'ai pas capté que c'était un
métier où quand même on se tirait pas
mal de coups de poignard dans le dos
j'ai pas capter ça bon je suis tombé
dans des embûches un petit peu un jeu
c'est pas grave bien
joran vaut pas question amour ça vous a
rapporté des gonzesses quand même non
bah oui normalement relais j'ai la
faiblesse de croire que c'est quand même
mon charme personnel bien sûr puisque
marc onno mairie
non mais ça il fait bien tu ça il fait
non ça rapporte des gosses mais pas
l'amour forcément le meilleur moment de
cette époque c était quoi ça a été la
radio parce que la radio ça m'a quand
même permis de de faire la connaissance
de jean que que j'idolâtre et mais moi
la première fois que j'ai reçus bécaud
par noël dans les roues kasri et
d'europe 1 je me rappelle quand j'étais
gamin quand j'étais adolescent on
faisait la queue à marseille pour aller
le voir au théâtre du gymnase mais après
le spectacle on resté deux heures dans
l'espoir de l'apercevoir moi j'étais et
quand je les ai reçus à europe 1 ça a
été c'était un grand moment d'émotion
c'était ça a été de connaître des gens
formidables
serge gainsbourg et même de nouer des
amitiés après ces gens là c'est un beau
cadeau ça et le pire moment c'est quand
j'ai commencé à être fatigué et surmené
je commençais à picoler un peu pour
tenir le coup ce qui est impur d'aidé
et des conneries à faire mais bon
vraiment je faisais trop de choses je
faisais la radio la télé les gars là
ouais j'avais un entourage qui était pas
très complaisant là dessus donc vraiment
pressé le citron et même la moelle des
pépins est ce que je serai bien c'est
quand j'ai commencé à tomber dans des
trucs un petit peu la picole pour tenir
le coup donc j'ai perdu le jugement j'ai
perdu le gélat je me n'est plus du tout
le truc quoi ouais ouais ce qui s'est
passé en 81 vous avez un deuxième fils
vincent qui naît autiste
ça sera fatal pour votre couple
évidemment c'est un petit peu aussi ce
qui vous pousse j'imagine dans l'alcool
non c'est à dire c'est une accumulation
de choses c'est à dire quand on se
tourne à droite à gauche devant derrière
on aperçoit des problèmes et on en
aperçoit aucune solution
il faut être très fort pour pas tombé
dans l'alcool ou autre chose bravo dieu
merci je suis pas tombé dans votre dent
de choses ouais ouais ouais un peu
d'alcool c'est quand même quand on veut
le truc mon poing duraquois un coin
alors vous vous referai un petit peu
entre 97 et 2000
et puis après nouvelle éclipse donc là
vous avez des problèmes avec le fisc à
ce moment là non je te prête le solde
non là vous êtes ruine et à ce moment là
non ça m'a jamais gêné parce que comme
j'ai commencé avec land à l'heure avec
50 francs en poche je me suis retournée
et 40 francs après je me suis dit j'ai
perdu 10 francs dont ces problèmes c'est
pas énorme
puis bon
j'ai toujours travaillé s'élargir
commencé à faire les cabarets donc pour
m'en sortir
ouais j'ai recommencé à faire des
spectacles bon quand on veut s'en sortir
puis quand même son métier c'est une
chance de ne sont hélas il ya eu des
moments dans les moments difficiles là
quand même vous étiez un peu un peu sdf
quoi un moment où vous étiez un peu
comme ça vous viviez un peu à la cloche
non sdf non mais bon sans logement oui
c'est à dire de dormir dans des hôtels
puis c'était surtout moralement parce
que on s'aperçoit que bon quand aux
contours des connu dans ce métier quand
ça quand ça rayonne
on a beaucoup de copains puis quand ça
rayonne plus on en a plus ça ça m'a
beaucoup blessée mais sur le plan sur le
plan personnel pas tellement pour
l'argent je m'en suis sorti ouais mais
ça bon devoir d'aider des copains qui
m'ont royalement snobé quand je vais
rencontrer ou carrément tourné le dos ça
m'a fait mal alors en 2005 on vous
retrouve dans une émission de télé
réalité la première compagnie et c'est
dans cette émission que vous demander en
mariage florence qui deviendra votre
quatrième épouse
voilà et qui est mccaffrey m'épouser et
hélas dernier et la dernière elle n'a
pas une vie facile elle aussi un donc
finale n'aurait non plus et vous
remonterez un petit peu ensemble ouais
on s'est connus on s'est connu tous les
deux on peut dire en bas d'échelle pour
des raisons
différentes mais on était on était très
mal moi quand elle m'a connu j'étais pas
un cadeau j'étais encore dans le j'étais
encore dans l'alcool
j'étais dans la dans la dépression
j'habitais un tout petit truc dans le
xvième volontairement j'avais pas de
téléphone j'avais une petite fenêtre
c'est un genre saint-jean de deux
cellules et c'était ma voisine du dessus
et me voyez comme ça alors comprenez
vous comprenez pas disais quand même ce
type il est connu mais pourquoi il fait
ça s est intéressé à moi mais elle aussi
était pas bien parce que la santé d'une
autre d'une histoire d'amour très dur et
donc on sait on sait remonter tous les
deux aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique
de l'époque du bébête show des
cocasseries tout ça a pas du tout avant
pas du tout je suis pas nostalgique je
je je suis fier je suis fier parce que
on souvent on me demande si la cie la
télé me manque
moi je trouve que c'est moi qui devrait
manquer parce que franchement toutes les
émissions qu'on m'a confié ouais ça a
été des gros cartons et bien sûr je pars
avec de bons états de service est vrai
dans leur mémoire franchement je pars la
tête haute
est-ce que vous avez la rancune pour
certaines personnes aujourd'hui
si la déception c'est la rancune
alain étant mais non mais c'est pas la
honte une parce que bon j ils m'ont
tourné le dos j'ai fait pareil et puis
voilà on passe on passe à autre chose
finalement on est bien que sur scène
quoi dès qu'on sort se retrouve en
coulisses on est si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil genre je fumerai pas je boirai
pas l'alcool ça vous a beaucoup coûté
oui ça a été une grande connerie de ma
vie franchement ça dure et qu'en même
temps
wow ça a bien duré une dizaine d'années
quoi le jour vous allez mourir qui se
voulait qu'on écrive sur l'autre tant de
gens et bien pas par exemple
désolé de ne pas vous faire rire c'est
très heureux de rallumer la lumière
seront versés merci thierry les
corrections de ne rien rater de finale
andy tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux